our topic for today and wednesday is
relation extraction
and this is an exciting topic both
because it's a great arena to explore a
variety of nlu and machine learning
techniques
and because it has so many real world
applications as we'll see in a moment
so here's an overview of the next two
lectures i'm going to start by
describing the task of relation
extraction
what it is why it matters and how we
might approach it
then i'll describe the data resources
we'll need to make headway on the
problem
next i'll provide a more precise
formulation of the prediction problem
that we're taking on and i'll propose a
strategy for quantitative evaluation
then we'll establish some lower bounds
on performance by evaluating some very
simple approaches to this problem
and finally we'll point toward some
directions for future exploration
in the first section i'll start by
defining the task of relation extraction
and then i'll try to provide some
motivation for why it's an important and
exciting problem
i'll describe both the vision that
originally inspired research in this
area and a range of current practical
applications for relation extraction
then i'll describe three paradigms that
correspond to three stages in the
evolution of approaches to relation
extraction
hand-built patterns which were dominant
in the 80s and 90s
supervised learning which became
dominant in the 2000s
and distant supervision which has
dominated since about 2010 and will be
our main focus
so let's dive in
so the task of relation extraction is
about extracting structured knowledge
from natural language text
we want to be able to start from a
document like this
this could be a news story or a web page
and extract relational triples like
founders paypal elon musk and founders
spacex elon musk
next we find this document
and we want to be able to extract
has spouse elon musk
to lula riley
we keep reading another document
and we want to extract
worked at elon musk tesla motors
if we can accumulate a large knowledge
base of relational triples we can use it
to power question answering and other
applications
building a knowledge base like this
manually is slow and expensive
but much of the knowledge that we'd like
to capture
is already expressed in abundant text on
the web
so the aim of relation extraction is to
accelerate knowledge-based construction
by extracting relational triples from
natural language text
here's a nice articulation of the vision
for relation extraction this is from tom
mitchell who is the former chair of
machine learning of the machine learning
department at cmu he's also the author
of one of the first textbooks on machine
learning
by the way he was also the phd advisor
of sebastian throne and oren ezioni
he wrote this piece in 2005 describing a
vision for machine reading and he
offered to bet a lobster dinner that by
2015 we will have a computer program
capable of automatically reading at
least 80 of the factual content on the
web and placing those facts in a
structured knowledge base
i think we've come pretty close to
achieving that goal and this is exactly
the goal that relation extraction aims
at to extract structured knowledge from
unstructured text
one of the things that makes relation
extraction an exciting topic is the
abundance of real world applications
for example nowadays intelligent
assistants like siri or google can
answer lots of factual questions like
who sang love train
to do this they rely on knowledge bases
or kbs containing thousands of relations
millions of entities and billions of
individual facts
there are many different strategies for
building and maintaining and extending
these kb's but considering how enormous
they are and how quickly the world is
creating new facts it's a process that
you want to automate as much as possible
so more and more
relation extraction from the web is
hugely strategic for apple and google
and other companies
in fact in 2017 apple spent 200 million
dollars to acquire a startup called
lattice which was co-founded by stanford
professor chris wray whom some of you
may know
specifically for this purpose
another example is building ontologies
uh if you're running an app store you're
gonna need a taxonomy of categories of
apps and which apps belong to which
categories
one one category of apps is video games
but if you're a gamer you know that
there are sub categories
and sub sub categories and sub sub sub
categories of video games and new ones
keep appearing and new games appear
every day how are you going to keep your
ontology up to date
well there's a lot of people writing
about video games on the web so maybe
relation extraction can help
the relation between a category and a
subcategory or between a category and an
instance of the category
can be a target for relation extraction
and similarly you can imagine using
relation extraction to help build or
maintain ontologies of car parts or
companies or viruses
another example comes from
bioinformatics so every year there are
thousands of new research articles
describing gene regulatory networks
if we can apply relation extraction to
these articles to populate a database of
gene regulation relationships
then we can begin to apply existing well
understood data mining techniques
we can look for
statistical correlations or apply
clever graph algorithms to activation
networks the sky's the limit we've
turned something that a machine can't
understand into something that a machine
can understand
so let's turn to the question of how
you'd actually solve this problem
the most obvious way to start is to
write down a few patterns which express
each relation
so for example if we want to find new
instances of the founders relation so we
can use patterns like x is the founder
of y or x comma who founded y
or y was founded by x
and then if we search a large corpus
we may find sentences like these that
match these patterns
and allow us to extract the fact that
elon musk founded spacex
so this seems promising and in fact this
was the dominant paradigm in relation
extraction in the early days
but this approach is really limited
the central challenge of relation
extraction is the fantastic diversity of
language the multitude of possible ways
to express a given relation
for example each of these sentences
also expresses the fact that elon musk
founded spacex
but in these examples the patterns which
connect elon musk with spacex
are not ones that we could have easily
anticipated
there they might be ones that will never
recur again
so to do relation extraction effectively
we need to go beyond hand-built patterns
so around the turn of the century the
machine learning revolution came to the
field of nlp and people began to try a
new approach namely supervised learning
so you start by labeling your examples
so these three examples
are positive instances of the founders
relation
uh so these are the positive examples
um
and
um these three these two are negative
examples
now that we have labeled training data
we can train a model
and it could be a simple linear model
that uses a bag of words representation
and assigns higher weights to words like
founder and established
that are likely to indicate the founders
relation
or it could be something more
complicated
in any case this was a hugely successful
idea
even simple machine learned models are
far better at generalizing to new data
than static patterns
but there's a big problem
manually labeling training examples is
laborious and time consuming and
expensive
and as a consequence the largest labeled
data sets that were produced
had only tens of thousands of examples
which by modern standards seems puny
if we want to apply modern machine
learning techniques we need a lot more
data we need a way to leverage vastly
greater quantities of training data
the answer appeared around 2010 with an
idea called distance supervision and
this is a really big idea
instead of manually labeling individual
examples we're going to automatically
derive the labels from an existing
knowledge base
so let's say we already have a kb that
contains many examples of the founders
relation so we've got spacex and elon
musk apple and steve jobs and so on
and let's say we have a large corpus of
text
it can be unlabeled text raw text
which means that it can be truly
enormous it can be the whole web
what we're going to do is we're going to
simply assume
that every sentence which contains a
pair of entities which are related in
the kb
like elon musk and spacex is a positive
example for that relation
and we're going to assume that every
sentence which contains a pair of
entities that are unrelated in the kb
like elon musk and apple
is a negative example
genius this gives this gives us a way to
generate massive quantities of training
data practically free
however
you might have some doubts about the
validity of those assumptions so hold
that thought
distance supervision is a really
powerful idea but it has two important
limitations
the first is a consequence of making the
unreliable assumption
that all sentences where related
entities co-occur
actually express that relation
inevitably some of them don't
like this example we labeled it as a
positive example for the founders
relation but it doesn't express that
relation at all this doesn't say that
elon musk is is a founder of spacex so
this label is a lie a dirty dirty lie
making this assumption blindly has the
effect of introducing noise into our
training data
distance supervision is effective in
spite of this problem because it makes
it possible to leverage vastly greater
quantities of training data and the
benefit of more data outweighs the harm
of noisier data
by the way i feel like i've waited my
whole life for the right opportunity to
use the pinocchio emoji
the day finally came
and it feels good
the second limitation is that we need an
existing kb to start from
we can only train a model to extract new
instances of the founders relation if we
already have many instances of the
founders relation so while distance
supervision is a great way to extend an
existing kb it's not useful for creating
a kb containing new relations from
scratch